see our judge Robertson Roswell and I
was the minority stockholder than the
manager of a radio station here back in
those days radio station kg FL okay and
we we had we got word of it with the
rancher himself word up there right oh I
beg your pardon of this UFO haha of
course there was a release that came out
of Walcott's Pio Department out of water
Air Force Base and so we followed it up
I did not go out because I to the crash
site I did not go out to the crash site
excuse me for being so hesitant about
this if I'd look at the camera instead
of your craft would be easier that's why
I'm sitting over here so you can talk to
me okay so that's it
be that as it may we so you were aware
of something going on out there and then
Rick Lee from Walters press release or
other sources other sources as a matter
of fact I don't know whether I should
say this or not but it was true we had
off the rancher for one night yeah where
yes the read we did it we did some
transcriptions with him and so forth
you know wire recorders in camera where
did you hide him out
we had about mr. whittemore's house here
in town he lived out outside of the city
limits on the east side so you were
present at the actual interview I was
not I was trying to run the station
the question that we ran into is the
very next morning some friendly person
probably from Clinton Anderson's office
called us from Washington and said you
are we understand that you have some
information and we want to assure you
that if you release it on this matter
because it's not supposed to be released
it's very possible that your license
could be in jeopardy and so we suggest
that you not do it and he said when I
mean in jeopardy like maybe three days
did was there any suggestion when you
got that phone call I mean did Walt
Whitmore hesitate about releasing the
information do you say well we're not
going to really
city so you got the call yes I was at
the office you see CW kwikmart with whom
I worked had different office hours in
here and I mmm he was a great nighttime
worker and he came down about 6 o'clock
at night to talk to me about the radio
business about the time since I've been
there since 65 good boy so you got the
phone call from Washington yes MA they
told you that your license was in
jeopardy did you they they indicated
that that would be a very negative thing
what convinced you that they meant
business and you were really talking to
somebody important and I even remember
who it was who identified himself was
there anybody confronted but he
convinced me because it already made
such a stir about the releases you see
to the newspapers and so forth and so in
other words the class went on the story
but this was not unusual for me because
I had been down here for a couple years
at that time from Minneapolis and with
things like air crashes and Walker Air
Force Base or the problems of that sort
it was not unusual for us to talk to the
people and they say oK we've got a
release date on this and not before not
before this time first we always part of
because they always tried to take care
of the afternoon newspaper
well that was that was where my question
was going when you got the phone call
from Washington was there any thought
about going ahead to release the story
anyway or did you just immediately kill
it no we did not we didn't think so we
did we didn't go over so when you got
the phone call you that was it the story
was done that was as far as I was
concerned okay
I saw no reason to do it because it
already had the disclaimers out there 10
tons of them talking about these weather
balloons and so forth so that was it the
point is that I was unable I never did
see the material I talked to people just
as you have bujji's well I'm sorry I
can't remember
can't remember
now you say you hit out or what Whitmore
hit out Brazel overnight on oh yes but
it was weg way tomorrow
yes Damon see now see here so he had a
45-minute wire recording of Razzles
interview that I don't know how long it
was those days with wire recorders only
these are guys all before your time and
if you recorded 15 minutes it took it
back to the studio and it took you 15
minutes to three one at 3.75 do you know
what ever happened to that wire
recording was race I didn't know I have
it at that particular time there were
there was quite a clamp on on discussion
of this and because there were people
who were all thought of people who were
pretty well convinced and myself was one
of them and I knew all of those people
out of walker because we had remotes out
there and we did lots of broadcasts on
there so I don't think that the I think
it we just decided it for Walt hot sake
and so forth that we would sit tight and
accept whatever it was even though in
our innermost minds we had real subtle
real question about the validity of it
usually had to ever treated a story like
this before they were created one had
they ever treated a story in this way oh
not in this particular way because this
was a highly unique experience or as I
say we were used to it because if there
were crashes you didn't say anything
about it until the people have been
there and all the listeners well yet
they've been embargoed yes miss Iceland
but this was a total plant down well I
would say so soon he was as far as we
were concerned there was no time limit
military as I've been such a event
before I can't tell you because you see
I just got down here in 46 when I came
those were in Minneapolis and so I had
run into that sort of thing there was
lots of it when we were in the missile
site business down because if there was
a problem we were advised and we were
out there with our blinking lights and
all that sort of stuff but we have we
held he said on those things until the
release of releases under people've
asked me because it had been a
discussion particularly after after your
broadcast and that that revitalized that
fact I was up in Creek Colorado last
week and a guy who hasn't been
interested at all all of a sudden he's a
fan and I sent him the book for more and
so forth when I got home here on the
weekend but but the point is that in so
far as I was concerned people say do you
think it was true and I said I don't
know but I'll tell you this I hard for
me to believe that in this
infinitesimally small area of the
universe that we were the only people
with any intelligence so if there are
and another thing that that histidines
because I had a friend who had a lot of
ours I think was in Northwest at that
time and he had I don't know how many
hours of him as Captain and when he said
he saw something off the left wing
here's a guy who but he makes a
statement if you're a disbeliever are an
unbeliever you say boy I want to fly
with him because I think he's on that so
he puts his own business in jeopardy
so W Whitmore had Brazel over night you
know did you actually see Brazel himself
- it was only when they first came down
here how did he come across to you I
didn't talk to you very much
we were frankly we were hiding the
things for Halloween and we didn't want
to make much of a stir on it
Whitmore's lived way out on each second
so that's that's about it did so the
Brazel is with what Whitmore overnight
you know did the military come and pick
him up or did Whitmore take him to I
think he turned it over wouldn't be fair
to say that Whitmore surrendered him to
the military or I got to colonic it was
just a guest overnight okay so so you
don't surrender a guest unless your name
is this guy over in Iraq but what the
military was looking for I think so yeah
what was done he would work hiding
razzle from the military or from your
rivals
he was he we just had a good story so
Whitmore was more worried about
protecting a story than the military
finding where Brazel was we had no
reason to hide him out keep doing the
except we wanted to some jockey to him
first
it so happened that it was all for
nothing because we didn't use it did
okay so that that next morning Whitmore
decided he wanted to go out to the crash
site
no I decided you the body glow they went
more Denham went on to the crash cider
yeah I think buddy I don't know he
couldn't get any closer tonight it I
thought we could do it with a banker
ruin or something so you followed the
back roads out toward Corona sure what
happened when you got out toward the
cause I just had some roadblocks that
resolved and when I was on one of the
back rooms well at the had the whole
thing
you used the word cardamom in the know I
think that might be a pretty one I
didn't pay that much attention to I
wasn't driving we had another guy and I
was more interested in just getting out
there and disappointed because believe
me we didn't get close you say another
guy you have to remember who that was
evidence why
we had about six people working for the
station so you went out to the to the
area we're stopped by the sure what how
did how do they do that they just say
sorry the roads closed this is a
restricted area
military men how would were they were
they in a jeep within a car I can't
imagine I imagine they're just one of
their blue sedans okay and as you
approach the fella came out on the road
and waved you down
as a matter of fact the reason I'm so
vague I don't mean to be intentionally
is because of that thing it wasn't
really a big deal because it had these
experiences before were some accident
had happened and where they just kind of
blocked off the whole area so it was
perfectly reasonable as far as I was
concerned
so you didn't get out to the site you
would turn around that point came back
to Roswell how close did you get broker
I'd I'll bet I wasn't within 15 miles I
don't know I have any idea because at
that time let's say it wasn't important
we wanted we wanted this see the stuff
we heard about and of course by that
time it was all picked up certainly that
day
that's about the story you said it stuff
you heard about what did you hear what
you call well one of the things that I
still remember specifically is that the
material they said was as thin as the
wrapper on a Lucky Strike package but
you couldn't break it and if you twisted
it and scrunched it up together it would
it would come back to its own meal they
tried to burn it and so forth and it was
like it was like it was it was a good
mystery for a small town but of course
we had a large at that particular time
we had a lot of military people here as
you know to notice any extraordinary
military activity in town event first
everybody started watching this guy so
there was an attitude within the town
itself all very aware and the night my
thought was looking back to the old days
of the invasion if you remember War of
the Worlds it yeah and the effect it had
on people on the East Coast but you can
and I thought that perhaps maybe this
was a good reason I have reason not to
believe that there was more than just
protecting the public from getting upset
over something because after that you
know we got into little Lubbock lights
and all of these sort of things and
people that I knew who were highly
respectable people longtime guys
ranchers and people like that we saw
some of these things and they had no
reason to they had no reason to kid
anybody about standing outside of their
pickup and watching these lights go back
and forth up in the mountains they're
not that they're not the sort of people
who needed to do that or was it their
nature to be the sorry
person around the station what was the
general reaction to the weather Bullock
story Delhi weather balloons were being
launched about a block from us every
night from me because they did that with
the did that would be one of your at
that time that's how they got their
meetings so weather balloons per se were
not that not that interesting to us so
you didn't buy that explained where did
he dinner but we didn't have any good
reason because that material was
scattered up there as you well know and
it was like being able to see if where
something goes down and there's a hell
of an explosion and a big deck dark
place did you ever have a case but talk
to say Colonel Blanchard or any of the
people out at the base after this event
and subsequent years and learn anything
from them maybe they said something to
you oh I don't think so
bill Blanchard was one of the first guys
I knew out there because he had served
them under my uncle who is a general in
the Air Force factories we had four guys
out there the commanders who involved in
students under him what used to be
killing
not in San Antonio so I always made an
appointment to meet those people because
they're nice people and we entertained
them a few times and then we going there
for a drink or something on vacation no
no we can discuss it that I don't know
why we did because that would have been
the time to to try to find out something
as
after Widmore turn razzle over the
military yeah you saw him after this did
he get was actually right you saw it for
certain [ __ ] the first chance you
had to ask him about the lawyer
recording I do not know in retrospect
why I didn't I just figured it was a
dead story and what I'm saying is that
Whitmore never told you what the rancher
said oh he had just just plain
discussion but but the rancher didn't
say much Rancher really said hey I was
out and I was riding and I saw this and
this is what it looked like and I
couldn't figure out what it wasn't and
so I came to town to tell some people
and mentioned it to some people and
pretty soon there was great interest and
so I don't think that that he himself
went in there and did a lot of pseudo
scientific experiments with this mr.
material there were all sorts of Satori
a month body's been loaded into planes
and all that sort of stuff and by the
first that first punch went right down
there were four worth two cars while the
rest of them I understood went back to
hell who was it accurately I mean Dayton
by idiotic Realty do you say others mean
other aircraft or yeah the presumption
was here any bizarre stories of aliens
running loose in Roswell at the time or
no like that no he did not he probably
would we've probably been too scared to
those after all that was all free et and
we didn't know how pretty these poker
so basically all you really know is a
little bit of what Whitmore told you
about the rancher finding the debris
coming into town and then attempting
yourself to go out to the site and being
turned back I'm receiving the phone call
now you're sure with Clinton Anderson's
office and not all no but I would assume
so
he's there senator could have been -
Evans oh well could have been Dennis
Chavez understood so from that prob was
good enough for us because at that
particular time you didn't go around
Grassley when the FCC if you can help it
they gave me enough trouble on other
things sitting out on a hill and
monitoring you a lousy 250 watts at that
time to make sure you weren't putting
out bad information all that information
and our or ASCAP was out there trying to
find if we were playing some of their
stuff and not reporting it so we had all
our government that we needed any
information about the rancher in the
next couple days no no I don't the have
impression where he was I do not recall
it's very possible
and all I know he did come back into the
station did he ever see Brazil after
that I know
that's not unusual these guys all the
appellant wrong way as you and we were
busy at that time I had a small small
staff three or four guys working from
the base we were working part time and
so forth and it was as I say in
retrospect we if we'd had any idea what
we had at what general interest it would
be why that then it would have been easy
and we would have obviously we would
have sat down and said let's see if we
can find out this and that put two and
two together and get something did the
military ever come by the station to
pick up press releases or anything like
that no indication the military came
back to make sure there was nothing left
behind that might no no I don't think so
because we were very close to the PIO
and they're a source of news
even if they had why I don't think it
would have been a great mental note
after all of these years because it was
was not that uncommon a situation
early years and certainly since
resurrection will story stories involve
any people that you've talked to any
former colleagues or anyone else that
ever voiced an opinion related any
Tibbets of information to oath of that
did that no because it was usually do
you believe this stuff and it so
happened that I believe that there's
some extent at that time and then
ultimately I just know more and more
that this was impossible
it it was it was nicely hushed up let me
put it that way
that's a gentle way of late so you you
weren't that concerned that the military
came in and suggested that you not
release the story that sort of thing
happened on a regular basis yes well
there was an aircraft accident or maybe
something that was see we were trying to
cover all of that stuff at the local
level because that's what we had that's
all we so the two stations which others
associated or a period of time we always
had mobile unison we always had we could
broadcast and so forth and even in those
days if there was a story way we chased
it pretty hard but for this one you
didn't really think there was a story
because I didn't think we were going to
be able to do anything about it I
thought that whatever they were going to
whatever they were going to report
because I'm a the question was in many
minds whatever they were going to report
that's what that's what we would tell so
the people would know there was no place
for you to go with the story
we had we had a discussion with a guy
who'd found some stuff but that they did
they did a good job of closing that
thing up Marcel was out of hearing I
don't know for five days I made it there
was there were there some people that
were shipped out maybe there maybe that
had been planned for 90 days but the
coincidence of it made people say boy
get him out of here
was there much talk among the
townspeople well then who is sure most
exciting thing in happens is they sold
the price bull at the 4-h center coming
all the big news yes I mean secondary
secondary story but next of the global
was there any general tone to the public
reaction that they believe that they
didn't believe it whatever I wouldn't I
wouldn't have any idea because I never
did run a poll or anything like that I
would suggest that there were some
people who said boy this must be a big
story or they wouldn't have made such an
effort and others who said some nut and
saw whether there was or whether rule
and that's good enough for me if we told
it was a winner poem by Jordan which
side were you on
I was in the middle between the 10th
time I am obviously have gone to the
troll there was such a thing now but
only on the basis of a small small-bore
logic that has to repeat myself if we
think with this little dot and it's
getting smaller and smaller all the time
even though this thing isn't working too
well up there now but the the fact is
that that for us to consider the fact
that we are the only people with the
intelligence to do that and has been so
much stuff to the contrary since those
days
I don't know all I know is I think that
to keep repeating myself but you don't
need to do but you could cut it I
presume the point is that why should we
think in this in this bill or we'd see
part of the universe that we are the
only people who are ever created with
any intelligence I know people who think
there there are other intelligences in
space that are perhaps way ahead of us
and this might have been maybe somebody
came down and said hey we saw some
flares down on that little old place
over here on me on the atomic test we
saw some flares we thought we'd send
somebody down and take a look see what
was going and so they did and think they
had the misfortune to do some bad
navigating or something that's a new way
of putting it
how did you know which branch to go to
because we had talked to the guy when it
came to town he actually told you to
change directions or told you and all
these old timers knew for exactly what
Ranchos everybody knew where all of the
branches big branches attention
no I I was I was busy in the station and
that was a very busy seven day a week
job because we covered sports and we can
read this and we covered that and I did
all the selling of all the advertising
but little there was so it my job was
was to stay right there and run the
thing written work himself was an
absentee owner
simple stomach
looks like that's it then there's this
deposition over there I believe so I
think you've got a heck of a job well no
I'll turn this off for ya how's that
what we're discussing
they thought it okay that they never
bought the idea that it was a reflection
from somebody's glasses down on the
ground I'm just putting the date on this
now so that we've got a picture of you
with the date no I wish I could be more
helpful because I'd love to see you guys
come up with some real solutions if you
define it
we're getting there yeah are you putting
the little bitty pieces together back we
go with the whole timeline together
which is why your story is important
because you have a couple of little
pieces that help fit it into the whole
chronology I can never convince you how
important story is to us well I realize
because because I'm I'm impressed that
you are willing to take the pieces but
that's that thing is pretty well
shattered now if you have to pick them
up to it you shattered and it's old and
final oh yeah see that's my big problem
hallucination I don't know why so well
we're we're rolling now we've got the
tape going so you're mrs. Lyman
Strickland Marion Strickland yeah and
we're here in Roswell New Mexico
oh yeah number 27 it says right there on
the official thing and we'll turn that
off and so let's go you were saying you
knew Mac Brazel yeah he was a neighbor
and you lived out near his ranch in the
summer of 93 is joined on the corner
they cornered okay
which direction every southeast of
Corona
and the cornering was in the same
direction southeast groan so you were
farther from Corona than Mack was no he
was further Oh
that range belonged to Foster's you knew
that how long before the summer 47 we
moved there in 1939 and I had three
small children
excuse me [ __ ] can we help you out with
anything there turn metal yes back on no
that's okay we're talking about Matt bow
on well we moved there in 39 and I had
my youngest child was only three or four
months old and I didn't get around to
meet neighbors but my husband did and he
undoubtedly knew bactrim very soon after
we went there we bought the place in 39
so Matt came by he would stop and
sometimes at the bar and sometimes he
came in the house I just grew up the
very friendly guy yes he was a very
self-sufficient country man
he was very dependable and
self-confident
he would not
stupid
it was not a highly educated person
moving ahead in the summer of 1947
leaping right ahead
you're of course aware of the events
took place in July of 47 yes now you
have no personal knowledge of what
happened you didn't see anything you
didn't go out to the crash site or
anything like that no you know I think
Mac went to see we were on a spur that
was off of the main line that went from
the foster ranch to Corona and
he would have gone by the proctors and
salty Myers first just on the way to
town but he would come out of his way to
come by our place but he came by and
told us about it and probably tried to
get women to go down and look at it now
he said he she know Sally is your
daughter yes okay we have two sons but
they're both deceased and she thought
that she could remember him well Lyman
and the boys to come down and kiss
she was one of the boys literally she
said that that was a busy time here if
it was dry and it was dry morning it was
anything else they were feeding her
Market lambs or one point
now you said you'd heard you remember
the thunderstorm oh yes because we had a
this is the house that was built later
we had a little dinky Shack that had a
porch that wasn't any wider than that
and my husband they're all ranchers go
out on the porch to see where it's
raining how much you knew got some and
he had to stand out there and see where
it was right hand there was so much
thunder and lightning that jump
I'm baby becoming the house and finally
there was this terrible thunderclap and
he came in and he says boy I read
something you know it has a different
sound meaning it has a hollow sound joy
he thought lightning had struck
something yes and it was three three
days after that that night
no it was longer than
it was a week or two did he didn't see
the lighting getting thing just know
that's hilly country and the clouds were
hanging low they were they were pretty
low so then you enliven nobody went over
with Mack to see the stuff no Mack went
to the proctors and maybe the so
tomorrow I don't know if he went there
but they didn't go down there with him I
guess everybody was busy in Mack thought
it was a weather balloon or some sort of
an experiment that he was glad to do the
government of favor of bringing the
pieces that's actually the attitude he
had when he gathered it up and took it
to town so he went keep brought it into
Roswell
when you say town Roswell and what
happened to him in Roswell they were
talking about that very secretly and he
didn't talk to me a lot but they were
around my table Mackin I don't know
whether Belle Brazil was their home I
don't
but Mac and my kids and Lyman and I was
busy carrying the coffeepot I really
heard more sketches of the conversation
than if I were just sitting there
talking like we are here what what what
was what pieces of conversation need to
hear what you remember about that Nancy
the officers at the air base were to buy
nasty what did he elaborate on that he
did to them yes he he he was held for I
believe it was three days or three
nights of course ranchers all had
livestock in their growls that had to be
fed and that was there by himself and I
think he called bail bill is in the
Albuquerque come down to take care of
his livestock but they literally threw
me in jail and it was two or three days
later Lyman and Floyd Proctor had some
business with the Bureau of Land
Management which had an office I don't
remember where their office was man
anyway they came down here to the Bureau
of Land Management together and they saw
Mack being discarded by two I believe
two army men and I don't know whether he
had handcuffs on a hot I don't believe I
ever heard that I don't believe he did I
believe they dissenting about it because
we were all the whole neighborhood was
scandalized that the army that the
services would treat people people who
had good intentions did that never
mentioned what went on when he was held
on the base I didn't hear it
surely Walter hopped in
he was a lieutenant
I couldn't tell you because like I said
I was carrying the coffeepot
Mac was very secretive and I know that
he made his claim that he was not
supposed to tell less and not supposed
to tell laughs and I think nostra party
was not supposed to tell was that there
was any excitement about this material
now that's my recollection
but Mac was pretty unhappy oh you bet he
was a man who had integrity he was he
definitely felt insulted and and miss
you
and disrespect
so he was annoyed the way the military
premium immerse them knowing he made the
effort to come in with the material and
they treated in that way and he said it
basically at your coffee table and
elaborated that my dinner table
narrative didn't have a car
I meant that did it actually kitchen
tables like yeah was this the only time
that he talked about it did he ever
mention it maybe some other time sure I
don't remember him being at my table I
was in the house now lots of women are
brought to range women are around the
Corral to lock but I wasn't
he
he came to the house often home when we
built this new house he came and helped
lighting with the plumbing much that was
later but I don't remember that he ever
came during that time of stress and he
was he was definitely under some stress
and felt like he had been misused and
kicked around and this was right after
he got back Yeah right after they let
him go not too long and since none of us
really knew then what the importance of
it was I don't remember just how long it
was it might have been two weeks I don't
think it was two months did he talk
about the material uh yes he did
I remember he said something about that
you could crumple it up
back out now my daughter I have been
asked before if anybody had any scraps
of it and my daughter told me off on
business she was only ten years old and
she said she wasn't impressed with it
but the bell bretzel brought a scrap of
it up there and you was at the corral he
was not in the house and I know I never
saw any of it I never started off and
she said that it was very very thin that
I had done I so good and she was
familiar with fabrics and she said it
was like a very thin copper but very
tough and she emphasized the word stuff
and I said how big was the scrap and she
said oh six inches by eight or ten
and I think what do you reckon he did
with it she says well if they didn't
bills I don't believe they were people
who who kept a lot of
they didn't have their house clutter
like this
she says well when if he didn't realize
the importance so he probably threw it
away
that was just conjecture where's your
daughter now fort market Colorado and
it's Sally petaline II what do you think
it'd be all right if we talked to her
call her long-distance and chatted with
her Tom Keurig what do we have a phone
number uh yeah ha do you ever remember
Jesus yes I do you want to write it down
oh that would record it one day three oh
three day eight six seven day 502 five
that's her home telephone that's Sally
tattling Joey
now of course her husband and sons with
9-valent are they from this area are
they from Colorado
oh but she says bill Brava brought his
strap of a diaper take a look at well or
just a show to show and like I said now
she lived at the corral her daddy had
ordered her to the house she had her
horses so forth and she was out there
and the boys were out there and I
suppose they all stopped and that's the
whole family star-filled was concerned
and I don't know whether I was home
enough
so basically what you know is Mac Brazel
was held by the people at the base for a
number of days yeah he came to your
house and was irritated by the worse
than Aaron typified it by the treatment
of them again you heard some of his
discussion about what went on at the
base and then live and saw Mac in the
company of a number of I could say
something that's off of the record
back on the record when I asked you
about the thunderstorm you thunderstorm
did anyone else comment if you hear
anyone else comment about the function
or the story I asked one either about at
one time and she said no she didn't
remember it because she had little
children her children by 1947 mine were
seven eight years old
and her four babies and I think that's
what she said that she didn't remember
that thunderstorm I don't know if
anybody else did anyone else in the
family that commented about the Valen
about love Thunder thunderclap Sally
could remember
I don't know
sons of sander not living
if Mac say anything while in Roseville
that he was threatened or that day I
think he was threatened yes something
because he was threatened if he opened
his mouth he might get thrown in the
back side of the jail now he gave that
impression
definitely
he must not tell anything he said that
he wasn't supposed to tell anything yes
so he was angry but yet he also took it
serious yeah that he couldn't say
was that unlike him that he would yes it
was unlikely
buckle down against something this he
was a very upfront person he would be
likely to say what he thought and if it
fitted you didn't like it for so what
what would it take to get him to keep
his mouth shut about something a serious
threat more than is the physical threat
I think so
but I don't know any threat that was
given group like I said I was carrying
the coffee could they have done anything
else to try to shut him up
Mike want bribe in you couldn't bribe
Mike I don't think you good
I think he double up your spit back your
way I really do
I don't think he's that kind of person
does anybody else my name such remarks
about my waterin s gun as far as his
financial situation prior to the
incident I don't know much about his
finances his wife lived in found the
border and had a home there and I've
been there and it was a nice house
enough well it was just a nice house in
a nice part of town it wasn't
extraordinary in any which way but it
was a nice home and she had a pretty
yard with flowers and I don't know
whether she didn't want to live on the
ranch or what but the foster ranch was a
vicarage and probably the pay was
something important
any idea what a man would be paid to run
I'm going to ranch in those days
I know what we had play hired man only
hired I'm just by the day
what did a hand get per day back then a
con hand would get about $60 a month
five dollars a day from
it's hard work if it's somebody that
nobody was doing
like when they'll work or finish work
but I don't know what my
it wasn't anything you talked about
around the time
was there anything different about him
after this
you might have been a little more
reticent because he felt like he was
disgraced and he really wanted to square
himself with his neighbors I think
that's why he talked a little because he
was straight that the neighbors might
think he had done something
crooked nature
he might have
we might have been a little more
interested I don't know when we built
this house I said this passage in the
painting Lyman didn't know anything
about plumbing because he cut two pieces
of
of pipe and they were both too short
Matt come up and healthy and they put in
they put in the plumbing together now I
don't know if Mack was done that before
that or not this was in the early
fifties who view the picture one of my
sons to know did he get all these
pictures
he painted everything in oil and did all
the winter
anything that's in China I did I'm
impressed
he did this one by the fire yes Jeffrey
that's a story that's a story that's
really true that happened when my
husband was about 2 or 3 years old
we'll turn it off no it's okay
my son painted it from his father's
story about it at that time they had
done no fences are very few and lots
cobbles and they ran this was like the
Chisolm outfit but they didn't work for
Chisolm they worked for him and they
were they ran into the cattle from the
Pecos one to the mountains and anyway
these Cowboys went out in the morning I
don't know him who were half a dozen and
this one didn't come back so they knew
something that happened to him and
was the horse stepped in a home and fell
with him and broke the man's leg but not
horses Lee and the wolves could smell
the blood the skin was broken the Lukas
mobile
and the wolf could smell the blood and
if National Geographic and they did I
read it if they want to tell you that
wolves won't attack maybe they won't if
they're just one but where there's a
whole ring of wolf a bunch and they
smell blood they would in any way he
could he had little chips would that he
got on fire and throughout him all night
long and they found him the other
Cowboys found in the next morning and my
mother called Lyman's mother walked up
to it and says there's Funko bear cream
right there that's one of the chips come
from
my son had never painted a tree he never
painted a tree until I insisted any
penalties there around the house and
those are no he didn't put any tree and
her sister and Jenny walked up to it is
that somebody else in the room says well
if you know what she says well he sure
was a good answer there's been a big
anything so I guess he goes those are
beautiful pictures yeah
thank you I treasure everything here
sure my son was selling at the time that
he died and he had sold several
portraits
the people who had commissioned
portraits came and gone but I kept
everything else on her songs
I just plastered the walls with
different the green doors in what is it
did you paint I paint China and then
what and what I'm here did you do well
this cabinet is full of it or that
cabinet is full of it and the everything
except one or two antiques and these
shelves that's always where you learned
it from yeah
how about these cups with birds I
painted all it's incredible I don't you
that's marvelous
now I didn't paint the virgin that's in
the window I did about half of the birds
or more than half maybe
laura's on the Trinity oh yes I did
almost
ah really realistic
I've enjoyed doing it my son was
painting at the time that I found the
lady who gave lessons and that was her
husband came
and I thought well I've always enjoyed
the China and I'll do this so I don't
interfere with his work like he had
talents that I've never had Todd
Levinson you've got a lot of talent but
it's obvious that he had lots of talent
too there was pretty much a sideline for
he was 40 years old when he died
and he had really just gotten into the
artistic
he drew from the timings years old
things that you can that align his
mother things that you might say it's
awfully good he drew one that I had on
the wall until it turned yellow and it
was a cowboy standing by a windmill and
the windmill was much taller than my
Givat the cowboy was much taller than
the windmill
so you know who was the most important
but both were very good and he was
forward when you
that I have painting to his
have a brand
grandson
two groups
this dog one of them is an art teacher
well if you don't mind I'd like the
video the paintings I'd like to I don't
know I don't know if it will come out
how good it will be but I'd certainly
like to give it a shot
and you say this is his house or your
house
after we moved in here and I mean what
was going on he had five little strokes
but he had gone coma
and
son and I were specific answer this is a
this is done from a photograph but this
one
worked a lot of mediums oh yes
except he had come on was treated for it
for several years and kids I thought was
such that this side of a woman wouldn't
ride with me except on a ranch where it
didn't matter and but we were coming
back from Rossville with lovey I was
driving we had a three quarter turn
usually love it with your free time this
is one possible
this was it maybe in the fifth
I couldn't tell you exactly
it didn't have anything to do
have you been I guess you've been the
Kurama yes and have you cross the Gallo
and then gone up by what was the
Reynolds ranch there's a long straight
road right up at the top of us I call it
a Mason
if it stretches for at least two or
three miles just as straight as a river
you come up from a deep draw and go up
on this long straight road well come
back rough roads
this is going to go jump at the car but
it's fifty nine miles out here and then
it cuts off the hook wrong it wasn't
paid thing and anyway
go back to 1942 about 1942 there were
lots of army planes going over because
that's right on a direct line between
him Albert and there was one that had
the bomb site if you remember they had a
bomb site that they protected with men's
lives and the planes were fixed so that
they blow up if they didn't land just
properly well anyway this plane circled
every this was night we had gone bad it
was about 10 11 o'clock and nearly
everybody had ten reps this was 1942
you could see the tenor of shining and
whatever like there was and this plane
you could tell it was in trouble because
the way the motors and they sound they
circled every ranch house in that area
ours included and by the time you think
of what to do to go down to the field
with your pickup and shine the lights on
the first the way they ran or something
they were gone and gone on to some other
place
anyway they spotted this this long road
brush later and they tried to land
they Carden that off for a week yeah
they're not
anyway this is 1950 I was driving real
slow and I found the diode which is very
sandy you don't cross the guy over just
anywhere it's so sandy that you could
bump down in the sand came this red
light mr. rounders a large red pulsating
light came up out of the guy who came
directly at us and all I could think of
we were up on this long road all I could
think of was that it was a plane with
that was in trouble when we trying to
land and I I know that Lyman agreed I
must we must have talked something the
bar [ __ ] was awfully deep and we went
off on that side wondered the thing
didn't turn over with the load we had
but anyway he got out and run down the
hill and I had a heck of a time to
getting my door open but I did get out
and I saw it not through
when she and this light came right
straight over us and stood there justice
still and all at one time it took off in
another direction now it didn't occur to
me at the time until the next day there
was not a thing
no roadside pickle death I was outside
picked up I was not singing it through
glass
there was not any safe and I said Lyman
I'm going to call we had to telephone
the land too and musta had part of this
house built and I said I'm going to call
White Sands Hotel and they lost one of
their Rockets he said you just shut up
and don't say one word they don't make
the food out and they already had
tertiary people insane things and I was
just convinced it with some earthly
thing that had gotten loose but I would
like to ask you all is there any theory
of anybody has had a theory that this is
a light thing I mean like we send the
searchlight the searchlight doesn't make
any sense you throw a baseball through
the air and it makes a sound and I can't
help but think that if it appeared to me
that this plane was
not over a hundred feet above maybe not
lost
my jacket retail pitch-dark it was
something I've never seen before and has
anybody arrows the weather player yeah I
remember there was nobody goes no
nothing like that
for hundreds and hundreds of reports
like that I heard they got like same as
anybody said that it could be us up
something that's beamed from somewhere
else
your guess is as good as anybody else
speculation theories about holographic
projections that almost appeared to be
three-dimensional from the projector
this not even a solid object it's just
the projection mr. ball the light well
this was a purely lighting red-brown
playing what shade of red I'd say it was
a little [ __ ] yo
lots of ribs or more orange-red yes if
I'm going to my palate I pick up your
red but it would be an entree
well we even have lots of reports of
huge vehicles hovering over people's
heads with no sound at all and I can
tell it's a baby
yes day time and no Sun well how do you
explain that because doctor said you
throw a ball for the air and you've got
sound the theory there is - that somehow
the object is able to with some type of
a for a field that would surround the
object actually draw the surrounding air
mouth with it that would serve a cushion
it is eliminating the friction the air
friction something you're
I don't know it's thinking Greek but
really whatever we don't know there's no
friction other business goals well you
know what a sonic boom is is hard
because that's where the air is
separated by the supersonic jet and as
it comes together to collapse so
whatever this is it doesn't caused it it
doesn't a lot to come together it
doesn't seem to have to come together it
seems the beetle break in the air that's
where the theory that is actually
drawing your with it see to when you
have an object that moves that fast that
the friction would cause it to start to
glow that's where like a meteorite
breaks up or even a satellite in reentry
would burn up as it comes into the
atmosphere we don't get that the thing
was in the meteorite because it's good
they're like they were seen have smartly
works if they wanted to ask us a few
questions I don't know decided they
didn't how long did it sit there you
know you're under such a stress at the
time it's hard to cut
I would say a few seconds might be
gently not more than three to five
minutes but you are moving in the truck
inside no - stop the truck
good stuff yes was it up ahead of the
truck as it appeared to hover or was it
overhead right overhead right overhead
if I had been in the truck I couldn't
have seen it but I you know it's hard to
open a pickup truck doctor the way sure
I did when I first saw it rip my husband
had run off down the draw and he kept
hollering at me to come on out his side
not really I think I was afraid that the
pole pick up a turnover because that was
a deep garbage I've heard that they've
got that road pavement
mortgages ago that one mistake and
anyway I remember struggling out on the
driver's side and stood there because by
that time by the time I got out I could
see that it was not a airplane that was
trying to land and come down the road
that's why would this have been in 1949
it could be I couldn't swear to the date
I hold an awful lot feet by myself his
eyes got so bad that when it is eyes get
better I guess he had some eye problems
from
the time my first name but they were not
treated until late doors
the left I'm referring to like a huge
line from
for five years
and he died quite a few years ago
take care well six years ago seven years
a
anyway he and plenty something Marisol
some friends I don't know if they were
going alone either
and I saw one looked like a campsite
about 11 o'clock at night one night not
like this was a pretty road went from
Sotomayor Air Force and
we have had a lot of sheep Stephen I've
got a snapshot over there where treats
put out through you know a sign that
there would be
that they would pay
they would pay for information on
rewards yes a reward and I wanted my mom
to call plenty and of course guy Matt
elated talking that this campsite was up
above there had been little rubber and
plenty since life that road washed out
to where nobody can get in there and
they went up there the next morning and
come around from the top side and they
said they found a dead livelihood zakat
evidently you know I don't remember but
I do remember what looked to me as I
passed it like like lighter lights that
would show through a tent
you're some of the opens
anybody moving around buddy see I was
driving I didn't want to set fire that
was cheap Steelers white foam and I
didn't know that the rotors
it was inspector then in our pasture
there was a bluff on we call it the
banana
to me it would be a hundred feet down
maybe it's not more than 50 but they had
it fenced off so the livestock will come
out fairly raised and fall off and it
was very rough you couldn't get up they
would pick up or even a jeep because
pieces would fall out and fall into the
canyon below and that was above our
house and as we turned the corner to
come in into a ballgame one night would
come in after the ballgame here was a
life gone down like from one fence fence
post to the other
just clear I don't drink
friends uh this ball game you remember
anything about the weather
no I wouldn't have gone the weather had
been very threatening
we lived in a remote enough area and had
livestock that job oh I guess something
old stick-in-the-mud I just wouldn't be
gone not that crazy about sports my kids
were the boys were playing one
we've had an interesting time you know I
think so too
and we saw the first atomic bomb oh yeah
yeah saw the flag yeah and this is true
my husband was one of those that done
thought if you didn't want to get up at
3 o'clock in the morning you're probably
a little legacy and he shook man around
and he says come here look we just this
is some old house just had one well the
window about the size of that out on the
west side and he wanted me to see this
explosion and I didn't think it did not
see any mushroom we were in a direct
line from Alma Dora behind the mountains
but and it was very quite and it went
right straight up if there was a
mushroom I didn't see I got up look that
went right back to bed would you think
it was we talked about it a minute or
two and thought I think he suggested it
might be an ammunition though because
nobody knew what was going on over there
merit but it had been announced - and
that's what we decided it was and I
thought well it's an ammunition dump so
why you got me up here forward so I like
the bed I think he went and made coffee
had your any rumors about what was going
on if if so I don't remember it we had
a long drive and we also had planes that
we know they came out of town the border
have a base there that scattered
something that that dispersed the clouds
out here I've got a government bullet
I've got it
in the box I know where it is we took a
while ago find it anyway the ranchers
are really they thought that these young
boys were doing this they were buzzing
windmills too at times and they thought
they were doing some of it just on their
own just to be framed and they made a
protest and there was I can't remember
that magic claim for sure anyway the
general and came in from El Paso and he
told them that it was not his voice that
was doing that it was a group that was
assigned to experiment with the weather
and he gave us the address and what to
ask for and we got these bulletins this
one that I'm talking about and anybody
that asked for one after that didn't get
it they shoved off
tell us about the experiments the
experiments were going all up and down
the Rockies even into mountain and there
was a big experiment station right there
at the mouth of the Platte River where
they hit when they had that big flood on
flat 19
six
responded to I mean it
it was named
we got the first ever bulletins from
Antalya
Andersen's was
Center and down
we're just a bunch of Hicks
but they could see some of these planes
come in they were branded capture or
market lambs or something front I'm a
bunch of men around all the guy or this
Muslim that I rancher all the neighbors
got together bigger
and I can see something being
don't doubt beamed out of these planes
and planes going right you might say
into clouds or they appeared spanked
you could just go buy more fade you saw
this happen I didn't see that I thought
I thought planes come in one time we
were struck in that same drawl that has
that Bluff owner I was telling you about
but anyway the water had come down those
magazines are to be given away and you
can have any you want and we were stuck
and there was the biggest old black
cloud up above and we needed rain and
needed it back and we were just working
like crazy
get back it was my husband and its own
son and I get that pickup out the drop
because it wouldn't wash it away and
the planes command and finally somebody
know became there and local anesthetic
this this government thing they said in
so many words they were trying to send
the moisture into the into the areas
that needed it for dry land in farming
I think they nearly got sued they washed
away the CANSIM stockyards once which
serves them right
I think that's all we really need Marie
done some wonderful work for us well I
hope it's been worth something I think
the American people off to know what's
going on I can realize one reason that
this was kept secret to this you
remember arson well you're too young
well well we let him out for his papers
I do well anyway he had written a play
and I think it was in New York City that
was a downright Rock one of the world's
people from the other worlds we're
coming in the people in New York City
just painted as are well known to do
people in New York City anyway that's
the only reason I can see why there
can't be helped of course now they've
had so much practice you know being
dishonest yes a nicer richer they have
been
I used to the idea of their superiority
and learning it over the rest of we're
just the taxpayer
we're just children have to be taken
care of yeah we're just the taxpayer
yeah yeah a woman so what do you believe
crashed up by the foster ranch not
important so what do I think
well for several years I reckon thought
but it might be something that the
Russians were experimenting with but I
don't think so anymore I think perhaps
we have the greatest technological
advances of anybody in the world and
they haven't found any living people on
any other planets that they gotta come
from somewhere
so you believe was from somewhere else
yes unless we find that a group of
people in this world that are smarter
than we know about I don't think in this
world anymore
I think that'll lure them thank you very
much for your time we will make a copy
the tape I won't promise the quality
will be very good I'm back to back to
make two copies and send them to you
don't worry about you know it's there
it's very simple to do and it doesn't
cost any religion you have more sort of
our our payment for you helping us out
well thank you I appreciate it very much
okay
and your name is you can speak up it
won't hurt and we're here in del heart
Texas on October 1st and you were a
niece of Barney Barney out of his life
and you did date and I understand it
that they kind of raised you for a while
they were real close to them they may be
sent me over for treachery here and they
helped spoil my in they did not hit me
over there oh ha ha
so Barney was a civil engineer for the
Soil Conservation Service working in an
office in the qur'anic his office was
since a coral yes ok and you can plied
by the US government you know okay you
remember the story the Barney told but I
remember that he saw one time we went to
visit another political former husband
are married or after I don't recall the
date but he said that he saw a UFO fall
you mean he was out working in the field
and I understood that he threw down in
the set st. Augustine plane and he will
reserve one
and mirth fell and got nearly to the
side and there was a group of people
Helmut Jahn geological or archaeological
and they were over there but they got
nearly up to this UFO but it was close
enough to see some creatures or things
that it didn't look like human beings
down there and along came a government
truck no with government you mean I
guess it was definitely gonna go if
someone came along and I understood it
I don't know this army or why I think he
did turn big government trucks and they
told him to going back and forget they
ever saw now that's our line he wasn't
specific on whether it was army or
here's a Berlin did he have any clue as
to where the archaeologists came from he
did did he never describe the creatures
to you
I don't recall he said did he give you a
number you remember if they're around
and they were all dead so forth either
they weren't moving so he never said
that one might have been alive by the
middle I don't think he got that close
you know I mean he didn't get right up
to this
seems like there was a fence they block
it off
or if they make a move back but you
don't know exactly where this was other
than you think it was up in the I feel
that it was up in the daddle or
Magdalena funding the heater Liz the
hacker the high country and he didn't
give me any clue as to what side of the
plains it would have been on or when it
was closer to daddle or Magdalena and he
did I don't
did he ever describe the object itself
to you to anything about that do you
know I don't you know what he didn't
you've heard about all there's you know
we realized I don't recall it but he
said or what it's been put into my mouth
under you don't dinner not that
anybody's today anything what would you
then use what you've read and you've
read the Box you saw the unsold there's
programs and things that you talked
about and there's been talk UFOs ever
since
but your your memories that are just
pretty vague about what he said except
that I do know the city and that there
were creatures in it
and a sofa or whatever so and I believe
he did say describe it it's a round
thing but you know let's say I don't do
you remember you recall now in the
subsequent years what his feelings about
UFOs were what is your what your
feelings about what do you think yeah it
could be someone I know
so you believe based on what Barney told
you that flying saucers are real and
they're piloted by beings from other
planets
is that a fair set I don't know who
they're I just know that they're real
are they yeah but you trust anything
Barney told you on that was he ever
known to play practical jokes or spin
tall tales or anything like that oh I
don't know that he'd play practical
jokes but not spin so he was ready but
this he was serious did it ever come up
more than one time that you remember
so and you have really no clue sorry
call it so that's fine that's exactly
what we want is exactly what you
remember not what others may have said
or things that people might have said
but what you you recall yourself so you
really have no clue as to when he
mentioned this to you other than it may
have been in the 50s it was in the
middle or latter forties early
I feel like so it might have been 49 or
48 so it might have been right after
close to the time that happened do you
remember the context I'm sure you don't
remember the context of the conversation
how it came up at all but it made enough
impression upon you that you remembered
at least a few of the details anything
else that you can think of it so you
have I've tried you know like my brain
to you know it seems ridiculous that we
didn't discuss it later and we may have
busy and you do use William maybe a day
or two the time what given what you know
what Barney Barnett said to you what
you're feeling of the government claims
that there's no such thing no such thing
no validity Oh
okay too much opinion consecutive
government you know the government do
you think the government's hiding
information about UFOs from us and then
she must be he topped it if they're the
ones who came along and said be quiet
about the Barney did mention the
archaeologist did he mention anybody
else who might have been there wanna be
egg and all the kind of they don't have
any clue how many people were involved
nobody else there that I think you
okay well this was your short right
that's why we're open on that that's why
I put it on the end of the day yeah but
you have no doubt that Barney was
telling you the truth about this did
Barney ever have trouble with the
government afterward maybe with the
Internal Revenue Service anything like
that nothing like that that you can
remember no harassment from from the
government then he retired from the soil
conservation he's not thinking about
1956 because of poor health and then he
did he stay in Sakura Sakura moon in
1969 so he was returning
and Ruth what she moved to she sings the
car all year to enter
when she passed away sweat here in that
heart and fiber City probably 76 did she
ever mention this at all and never ever
brought it up I don't think you know he
just went on with what the president
wasn't really that major of an event in
anybody's life that I can't pop it and
even though you can't imagine it damn it
man I can't play down ok well I give it
imparted my friends back then you know
we might have been raising all right
well I think probably they say taken up
enough of your time so I'm gonna I'll
turn off the camera here it worked out
real well didn't it I don't know it
wasn't horrible or anything scary it was
scary